this is every succession wall prints
ranked ranked by their chances of
winning the war and of course ranked by
their General princelyess and we are
commencing with first prince Benjamin
who has an immediate unfair Advantage
because he was the first to be popped
out of his mother's birth Hall that's
very much how this whole War operates
nothing about this is balanced and the
older The Sibling is the more resources
they have to do the winning with
Benjamin's resources include his own
private military and in fact he is the
Deputy adviser to the entire cocky
military in general he also has a
ridiculous Advantage when it comes to
nen mostly being that he can actually
use it unlike the majority of the other
princes not only that but Benjamin is
like a nen tampon designed to absorb the
abilities of everyone around him very
much like a budget crawler Lucifer his
ultimate goal after becoming King is
checks notes world domination or in his
own words the unification of the world
under the kakin Empire so Benjamin's
victory means World War he's already
formidable and that's not even including
the guardian Spirit Beast that we have
yet to learn anything about so Benjamin
is kicking things off as an stf Prince
our next candidate is second Prince
Camilla boasting an inability that
prevents her from getting kill murdered
not only that but it's kind of like an
UNO reverse card you know you try to
murder me no no now you're murdering you
that's how it works I would say that
Camilla's biggest issue right now is
that her ability is no longer secret
Benjamin knows about it and he was
likely the only prince who would have
attempted to murder Camilla with his own
hands as Benjamin did promise to break
every bonus radnik's body with his bare
hands which is that's that's Charming
Camilla very notably is not seradnik and
even if she were I think the Benjamin
would be having some second thoughts
After figuring her ability out and you
know that's that's just the big issue
with net combat once your ability is
known you're probably done Camilla's
biggest Advantage right now is having
control of the have-nots a lower cast of
the cartoon Empire who holds such a
strong Grudge that they've evolved into
a legion of nen curse assassins pretty
amazing stuff but Camilla is also not
the most strategically sound of all of
the siblings and so palmasum as she may
be I think the Atia is appropriate if
not maybe a bit generous the third
princess sang lay and this is where
things get immediately unfair Rivera
because the third Prince onwards had no
knowledge of nen until the succession
War actually began which is kind of like
agreeing to fight a war without knowing
what a weapon is sang lay has a fun
quote though a true king makes use of
both light and dark sides of society he
is outwardly responsible if maybe a bit
too indulgent but of the three he would
certainly make the best King so far and
Zhang lay seems to agree because his
whole focus is on what to do after the
succession war ends which is reflected
in his Guardian Spirit Beast the ability
of which is hypothesized to only
activate one sang lay assumes the throne
he's incredibly intelligent but he's
looking so far ahead that he's not gonna
see the knife right under his neck he's
a b tier Prince he might be a great
leader for cocaine during peacetime but
I highly doubt his ability to survive
during wartime onwards to number four
and look I don't know what to say about
Sarai Nick that I haven't said Ad
nauseam in every other video except for
this what it comes down to with the
fourth Prince is talent and I hate the
word talent like really hate it I think
it gets used too commonly and it often
disregards the thousands and thousands
of hours at Artisan musicians just pump
into Mouse during their craft but every
now and then there is a rare artist who
can only be described as gifted managing
to reach higher peaks in a fraction of
those hours and that man is serratic
right now saradnik is not the strongest
not the smartest and he doesn't have the
biggest network of all of the people
right now he could be killed however
that chance slips more and more Out Of
Reach with every minute that he is left
alone to study now if this man is
allowed to live for even another week he
may very well become the most powerful
or reuser aboard the ship and that
includes the likes of crolo hisoka
karapika the zodiacs and even Beyond
nettera because even Beyond's father
Isaac natoro was not as talented as
radnik Isaac nachrow is an example of
what I said before a man who sunk
hundreds of thousands of hours into
becoming the aura monster that he was
but seradnik is a man who doesn't need
years he needs days right now he's a
clear s tier Prince but if he were to
live just a little bit too long then we
would have to open up brand new tier
above that to place him into but taking
a big step down now we have fifth Prince
to beppa and this is where our Chasm of
General unfairness grows ever wider to
bepper is the first prince we've
encountered that doesn't have control of
her own extended forces no military no
have not and no Mafia connections and
that's because tabepa's priority is
science glorious glorious science and
she has rather harsh views towards her
older siblings believing that each and
every one of them is a cancerous Prince
shaped tumor that needs to be
immediately purged from the khakin
Empire meanwhile all of her younger
siblings when they just need good
education and they will be on the right
path in all fairness Tibet would
probably make the best King so far
because she's the first that has some
degree of empathy and would definitely
leak Hakeem into a science boom but she
is very out of her League here with
little knowledge and even interest in
learning about nen combined with some
very underwhelming bodyguards and the
only reason why she isn't a sea or even
D tier Prince is because she has made an
alliance with saranya which alone
elevates to beppa into the beat here but
will six Prince Tyson fare any better
well Tyson is physical leader who
believes that she will win the war
through the power of love so probably
not Tyson genuinely despises violence of
any kind and refuses to engage in it a
very problematic stance when it comes to
the concept of War however with that
said Tyson does have a win condition the
thing about Tyson is that she is
genuinely charming and even cute if you
spend enough time with her you will be
won over which plays very nicely into a
guardian Spirit Beast who infects those
who encounter Tyson's teachings with
literal happiness so it becomes like a
drug the more you invest yourself into
the cult of Tyson the happier you feel
and given enough time that happiness
would spread and eventually control
everyone but Tyson does not have that
time given that her whole strategy is
certain weight it's much more likely
that another much more active Prince
Will snowball and engulf her also Tyson
does have a distinct weakness for
handsome men meaning that all it really
takes is a strapping six-packed assassin
to stroll on in and Tyson is in well a
less than great situation a situation of
death and that's why Tyson probably has
the worst chance of any Prince so far
and so she she is going straight into
the detail and that brings us to seventh
Prince Lazarus the man who all of the
other princes assume has the worst
chances of winning yes even more so than
the literal baby however loserus is
something of an enigmatic question mark
his Guardian Spirit Beast very strongly
hints towards deception as if embodying
the idea that Lazarus appears to be what
you want him to be so incestrydnick's
case that would be a complete and not a
[ __ ] because he has a superiority
complex to her to put a kindly meanwhile
in basho's case luzaris appears to be a
generous philanthropist keen on helping
the world but also in the case of the
mafia family that losers funds he would
appear to be a ruthless underworld boss
one point against him is that of all of
the cognitively aware princes luzarus is
the one who shows absolutely no interest
in learning men like none whatsoever but
then again is that also just deception
maybe he's already an experienced nen
user and just pretends to be ignorant
basically he's a complete coin flip
loser risk would be one of the strongest
contenders he could also very easily be
one of the weakest or just simply mid
and to average Bridge everything out I
think we need to place him in the beat
here to the rotund 8th Prince now we
find salisale son of Queen swingers
WinCo and never has a son looked more
like his mother in the worst way
possible Sala Salah took Tyson's
strategy of sit and wait a little bit
further because he thought why sit and
you can lie down and so he spent his
time lying in bed likely completely
unable to get up due to the critical
mass of naked women piled on top of him
his stereotype is that he's the party
prince in the general disappointment of
the family we all have one interestingly
his Guardian Spirit Beast also functions
similarly to Tyson's except since Sala
Salah was devoid of any Charisma the
Beast had to infect those around him
with favorable thoughts which they could
then spread to others who came near them
and I think that if Sala Salah had done
literally anything to defend himself
then he would have been in with a decent
chance not good but decent because I do
think that this ability is just plain
better than Tyson's but he didn't and
now he's dead which means we need to
open up a new tier of failure to plunk
salasala straight into the realm of the
dead from disappointment to overachiever
we now have ninth Prince hulkenberg a
man who went to the most prestigious
University in the world to study Physics
at the age of 15 and is also like really
good at archery he is the most morally
upstanding of all of the princes which
is worrying because tagashi often likes
to play with you know flipping morality
on its head so hulkenberg could become a
pretty terrifying dude in the future he
doesn't have the talent of seradnik but
he does have something equally as useful
which is that he is more driven to win
than any other prince and for genuinely
good reasons as well he wants to make
the world a better and more fair place
so his Aura has responded to that drive
and given him an inability said to be
Invincible in one-on-one combat plus his
Spirit Beast Buffs his guards and his
Gods buff his gods and I think that
hulkenberg now has the single greatest
concentration of power in the entire War
he is easily the best candidate from the
younger princes and is certainly in the
S2 however going further down to 10th
Prince Kat show we encounter a brand new
level of unfairness because now we are
dealing with literal children who have
no power and no influence figures like
contro strike me more as Gap fillers
people who were basically born just to
be corpses and sacrificed to make the
karkin Empire more powerful or because
there may be a strict numerical
requirement to princes for this
succession War to take place the only
thing that katro cares for in this world
is her younger sister fugetsu so let's
hope she has a better chance because
cart show is well and truly out of
contention due to a sudden case of death
and so lands very firmly in the dead
tier now speaking of fugetsu is
completely unremarkable in every way she
is a very realistic depiction of a child
a child who has made some unwise
decisions as all children do but in this
case not hiring any Hunters to protect
her was a bad move what fugetsu does
have going for her is that she inherited
kacho's Spirit Beast which in
combination with fugetsu's allows her to
essentially teleport wherever she
pleases via this very funky door
perfectly suited to fuketsu because it
reflects her drive to just not
participate and run away and it is
difficult but not at all impossible to
catch her either you need to be smart
enough to predict where fugetsu will run
and again she is a literal child so that
should well truly be within the ability
of some sort of Genius level adult or
even just regular level adult plus you
can also stop her ability entirely by
removing kocho's and end Beast fugetsu
has no desire to win even if she did she
has no win condition and honestly the
best thing that she can hope for is
survival and in light of this we are
going to elevate Tyson to the Sea tier
because even though she also has a
pacifist strategy at the very least that
pacifism is building towards a win
unlike fugatsu who is just stuck
constantly running running straight into
a big old detail now for another
delightful innocent young girl it's 12th
Prince momozo although is she really
that innocent I question this because
her guardian Spirit Beast immediately
launched a very aggressive campaign as
soon as the war started specifically
targeting Prince wobble aka the baby so
I do think that says a lot about mama
says inner thoughts and feelings this is
a very tragic story though because mama
said didn't have the aura required to
sustain the activities for ninbeast and
so it wasn't there when she needed it
most and as a result mama said is now
belonged in the dead tier sorry a
younger brought the 13th Prince Murray
I'm weirdly enough has a much larger
quantity of Aura despite still sleeping
in a crib able to feed this pretty damn
incredible Spirit Beast it might be
because maryam's Beast is more defensive
in nature because generally the further
you need your aura to travel the more of
it you need to invest together which
makes long distance aggression very
taxing Mariam is another certain weight
Prince because evil he kind of has to be
and luckily his Guardian Spirit Beast
seems to be protecting him with a pocket
Dimension ability which is going to be
very difficult to infiltrate or break
plus Mariam has two very strong assets
in his corner at the moment which is
that he is being guarded by both Hanzo
and bisky so a combination of sneaky
skills and raw power which very much
keeps him out of the detail and gives
Mariam a much more solid chance in C and
then we have the baby 14th Prince verbal
who not only has no concept of the war
but arguably no concept of life whether
this war goes well or not she will be
spending most of it asleep and while she
may not yet have manifested a guardian
Spirit Beast she does have karapika and
that is extremely overpowered and and
thus this baby will be sent flying
straight into the Atia for protagonistic
based reasons and that is every
succession War Prince ranked